it's five GMT that's 8 A.M in Turkey a
where polls have just opened in a highly
anticipated general election about 64
million eligible voters will be choosing
a president and Parliament for a
five-year term it's considered the
toughest vote for president Richard
erdogan was faced during the last two
decades he's been in power say nakoda is
following the elections in the
Southeastern city of antakia but first
let's speak to Russell Sada who's in the
capital Ankara so what could end up
being a Monumental day what are we
expecting
indeed Monumental this this election is
regarded as a pivotal one for turkey so
the polls just got open two minutes ago
uh we haven't seen anyone voting yet
however here you can see that officers
are making the final preparations The
Ballot Box is there and each party that
are in this competition for the
Parliament and for president they have a
representative there you can see the
voting cards are being prepared and we
see that some of the people outside of
this room waiting in the corridor to
come and to cast their their Wars so
here two candidates mainly two
candidates are for three candles are
fighting but two of them are very much
important here the first one is
president who has ruled on the country
in the last two decades and he wants to
be re-elected again so the second one is
the leader the candidate of the
opposition
who has United the opposition in turkey
and maybe for the first time
they might be about to win and if that
happens that's going to be quite a pivot
of they here in Turkey so today 64
million people over 64 million people
are expected internally and external and
abroad are expected to vote and the
candidates here need to surpass 50 plus
one vote to win outright if none of the
candidates passed that threshold then
the election will go to the second run
and it's going to be between the two
candidates who received most of the wars
and that is that is something that
turkey is not used to yeah turkey is not
used to the runoffs so if none of them
surpass 50 then the next two weeks are
going to be quite fast and resolving
voters cast ballots on what basis are
they going to be making their choice
awesome
well there are various factors here so
internally and internationally even
emotional and ideological lines are
going to play a crucial role so that's
why president erwan trying to appeal his
conservative base he was promising a
more powerful turkey a more assertive
turkey internationally and he was saying
that he and his government has made
turkey a regional power but now it's
time to make it an international actor a
global power so and on the other hand we
see that the opposition on the other
hand was trying to appeal its basis by
promising more the more democracy
greater individual rights and also
internationally having bad relations
with the West particularly but he had
one of the main issue is going to be the
economy so that's going to be quite
determinative in terms of the results so
Turkish economy in the last two years
was suffering skyrocketing prices one of
the highest inflation in the world and
that's why particularly the opposition
was focusing on that and promising a
recovery in the economy however as I
said president was focusing on
continuity and stability but the
opposition was promising change and hope
so we'll see who will be able to
convince uh the the the waters the
Turkish public today
there for us in Ankara we can cross now
to zainer hotter who's in the city of
antakia and hate province which is one
of the epicenters of February's
magnitude 7.8 devastating earthquake
Cena considering the devastation that
much of the province suffered during
that Quake what sort of logistical
challenges has this posed for voting and
campaigning
well first of all you got you have to
get the voters to the polling stations
those devastating earthquakes displaced
millions of people but we have been in
antakia's main bus terminal over the
past hour or so and I can tell you bus
after bus has been arriving here people
from across the country various cities
coming back to vote because according to
Turkish law you need to vote in your
place of residence and if you move you
need to re-register and not many people
did that we've also been speaking to
people here hatai was one of the worst
hit provinces it's also considered to be
an opposition stronghold people here are
angry they're angry at the government
they feel that the government mishandled
the aftermath of the earthquake they
feel that they were left alone and
they're still left alone so they want to
go to The Ballot Box in order to hold
officials to account but at the same
time we've been traveling across the
Quake hit provinces in in recent days at
the ruling party
still maintains support in their
traditional strongholds so it's hard to
say which way this vote will go but
every vote counts and this is why you're
seeing all these people coming back many
of them have been traumatized from the
earthquake it's the first time they've
come back we've seen people greet their
family members for the first time so
this is a major challenge getting them
to the polling stations even those who
are living in informal settlements they
don't even have cars what we understand
is that the political parties are doing
their best to provide transport to
encourage people to vote because like I
said a highly contested election means
every vote counts okay
speaking to us there from the
Southeastern city of antakia good to
speak to you we'll be speaking to our
correspondents throughout the day and
lots of analysis on the Turkish election